[Music]
congratulations your show is really
really funny thank you people love this
show
and what a great idea you play the vice
president I do and you have a lot of fun
with the fact that you're near the
prather been shows about the president
yes this is the first thing I think
there's about the vice president and
it's all about you really having nothing
to do no power well I mean you know the
tagline for the show is the buck stops
somewhere near here okay and and you
know if you think about it there I I
defy you to find one ambitious political
person who aspires to the vice
presidency right you know
No Child says someday I'm gonna be vice
president yeah yeah it's true and it's
it's you know it's number two you know
and in this country we revere number one
so much but number two not so much so I
mean it's it's a it's a good area for
comedy and as a matter of fact there was
a FDR went through three different vice
present right he was president for so
long that he had multiple vice
presidents yeah and his first one was
this guy named John Nance Garner and
John Nance Garner who's from Texas is
famous for having said to Lyndon Johnson
that the vice presidency wasn't worth a
bucket of warm piss right right I know
that quote yeah yeah yeah we quote
something bucket of warm piss worth
that's a happy note I more than cold
yeah could be worse a positive spin yeah
so you've done some work you've actually
you've read up a lot about vice
president I have and as a matter of fact
I have another quote you want to hear it
yeah this is from we're gonna learn yes
is good do this ladies and gentlemen sit
back take notes if you care to
this is glasses match your dress that's
hurt that's pure pure pure coincidence
oh I'm sorry I didn't know what you were
gonna say my medication just kicked in
anyway listen
this is front this is the first vice
president John Adams and this is what he
actually said my country has in its
wisdom contrived for me the most
insignificant office that ever the
invention of man contrived or his
imagination conceived thank you very
much haha pretty kind of bitter about it
I did well here's my question your show
really makes fun of the vice president
have you met our Vice President Joe
Biden I have met our Vice President Joe
Biden but this was long before we are
doing this show or it was even I was
even thinking about it it was back when
he was campaigning as a matter of fact
and I I went on The Ellen Show and he
dunked me in a dunk tank wait so you
were sitting in it's not like he grabbed
you and threw you into attack no no he
pitched a ball and I fell into the water
and that was what he was doing during
the campaign and and it's sort of a it's
it's I mean I love Joe Biden don't get
me wrong I think he's a great vice
president no doubt but um it's sort of
emblematic of maybe the gig you know
it's you know you're dunking go on Ellen
and 10:00 and dunk a celebrity it's fun
it's right because one of the I think
vice presidents also know they have to
have a sense of humor about it and not
long about six months ago I was at an
event that the Vice present was at and I
was with my father yeah and my father
really wanted meet the vice president
said oh yeah you know you know Vice
President Biden is my dad and and my dad
said Oh mr. vice president it's so thank
you for all that you do and and and and
Vice President Biden had a big sandwich
and he said well Conan here likes to
joke but I don't do anything ah oh yeah
bite of a sandwich and laughed all the
food came out of his mouth it was
disgusting
oh wait a minute let me ask you so he
what's he mad no no no no he wasn't mad
at all he wasn't no no one bites into a
sandwich angrily
[Laughter]